بين الياباني والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مسافه اكثر من 10,000 كيلو متر لكن البعد
الجغرافي لا يعيق باي حال تحالفهم
العسكريه والسياسيه الوثيقه القائمه منذ
نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه تحالف تدفعه
التوترات الراهنه في شرق اسيا والحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا الى افاق جديده تنزع
عنه كل القيود والمحاذير فاجتماع واشنطن
بين وزراء البلدين للخارجيه والدفاع تمخض
عن توسيع الماده الخامسه من المعاهده
الدفاعيه الثنائيه وتغطيه الرد المشتركه
على اي هجوم عبر الفضاء ردا على تزايد
القدرات الصينيه عبر الاقمار الاصطناعيه
اما تهديدات كوريا الشماليه فقابلها تاكيد
وزير الدفاع الامريكي استعداد بلاده
لاستخدام السلاح النووي لحمايه اليابان
تتخوف اليابان ومعها الولايات المتحده مما
تسميانه التحدي الصينيه المتناميه في
المنطقه عبر استعراض بجين قوتها العسكريه
وترهيب الجيران وهي مخاوف تفاقمها ايضا
التطورات في شبه الجزيره الكوريه حيث
تتدهور اكثر فاكثر العلاقات بين
الكوريهتين وتتساقط مزيدا من صواريخ بيونج
في بحر اليابان التحالف الياباني
الامريكيه الذي يدشن حقبه جديده من
المنافسه الاستراتيجيه مع بيجين سبقته
الشهر الماضي ترتيباته استثنائيه في طوكيو
التي اقرت مراجعه جذريه لعقيدتها الدفاعيه
نصت بالاساس على زياده ضخمه في الميزانيه
العسكريه خلال السنوات الخمس المقبله
وتعزيز قدره البلاد على الردع والرد على
اي هجوم صاروخي بما في ذلك استهدف مصدر
اطلاقها وذلك تحول هائل في بلد يمنعه
دستوره من تشكيل جيش حقيقي منذ هزيمته قبل
سبعين عاما كما سمحت تلك المراجعات باعاده
انتشار نحو 50,000 جندي امريكي يتمركز
اكثر من نصفهم في جزيرتي اوكيناوه
وتزداد هذه الترتيبات اهميه
تجيء عشيه قمه يابانيه امريكيه حيث يصل
رئيس الوزراء الياباني خلال ساعات الى
واشنطن قادما من كندا وغداه جوله قادته
الى اوروبا تزامنا مع استلام بلاده رئاسه
مجموعه الدول الصناعيه السبع الكبرى للعام
الحالي 2023